كلما اشتعلت نيران المواجهات المسلحه
وبرزت بؤره توتر في اي نقطه من العالم
طفائل السطح الحديث عن مجموعه فاجنر
الروسيه الاشتباكات الجاريه في السودان لا
تخرج عن هذه القاعده اتهامات لمجموعه
فاجنر بتزويد قوه الدعم السريع بصواريخ
ارض جو كانت مخزنه في افريقيا الوسطى
للمساعده في قتالها ضد الجيش السوداني
وزير خارجيه فنلندا قال ان ثمه مخاطر من
ان تستفيد مجموعه فاجنر من الازمه الراهنه
على الاتحاد الاوروبي فعل المزيد فيما
يتعلق بالوضع في السودان ليس من العدل ان
يغادر جميع الاجانب البلاد في هذه الظروف
اذا غادرنا فاننا نترك ايضا بعض المجال
لقوات فاجنر وروسيا للعب في هذه اللعبه
قوات الدعم السريع بقياده حميدتي نفت
الاتهامات جمله وتفصيله فهي ادعاءه خاليه
من الصحه وجزء من حرب المعلومات والاخبار
المزيفه التي تشن عليها تقول الدعم السريع
نرفض رفضا قاطعا مزاعم تورطنا مع مجموعه
فاجنر في الصراع الحالي في السودان
الازمه في السودان تستمر في التعمق مع
مرور الايام الاحداث على الارض تنذر بتفجر
الوضع اكثر فاكثر مع امكانيه تدخل قوى
خارجيه في الصراع كما حدث في مناطق مختلفه
من العالم فالتاريخ يصر دائما على ان يعيد
نفسه بلال البجدين العربيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات